[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean-baptiste lemoyne bonjour bonjour si
vous pouvez d'être avec nous secrétaire
d'état chargé du tourisme des français
de l'étranger de la francophonie on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour intel
juin en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour julien
lécuyer bonjour rien de la voix du nord
julien lécuyer
on commence par la crise sanitaire
jean-baptiste lemoyne et le confinement
à dunkerque qui est donc prolongé pour
trois week-ends supplémentaires alors
qu'il n'est pas envisagé en
ile-de-france a dit jérôme salomon bien
que la situation sanitaire soit aussi
tendue en ile-de-france où est la
logique du gouvernement
vous savez ils sont très proches très
territorial et on met en place en ile de
france d'autres types de mesures
effectivement il ya une tension spital
hier importante mais il ya un
fonctionnement qui se fait aussi en
harmonie avec les systèmes hospitaliers
dans l'ouest de la france avec justement
transfert de certains patients
et encore une fois ce qu'on voit c'est
que le couvre feu
eh bien il faut le respecter
naturellement il faut tous respectés et
les françaises lui rendre hommage parce
qu'ils font leurs meilleurs efforts on
leur a demandé de tenir encore quatre à
six semaines bon voie jusqu'à la mi
avril parce que à la mi avril c'est vrai
que il ya subjective des 10 millions de
vaccinés et à ce moment là je crois que
bien on peut envisager la vie
différemment parce que là on le voit
fragiles jeunes et plus non vous savez
il n'ya pas l'économie de vente où il ya
avant tout la protection des vies et
encore une fois
je crois que on fait tous le maximum
tout le monde se retrousse les manches
je regardais le coup d'accélérateur à la
vaccination partout sur le territoire en
ile de france comme ailleurs des doses
supplémentaires ont été envoyés
également dans le pas de calais
naturellement la semaine dernière pour
faire face à la situation
donc c'est un ensemble d'instruments
d'outils une palette sur laquelle on
agit pour avoir les meilleurs résultats
voilà il faut encore tenir quelques
temps mais c'est à dire quelques temps
monsieur ministre c'est vrai quoi vous
parlez en le le président de la
république a parlé de quatre à six
semaines
beaucoup de scientifiques sont très
dubitatifs sur 7 sur cet optimisme et
qui repose aussi sur la vaccination est
ce que vous êtes certains que le
gouvernement pourra tenir le rythme de
vaccination qui s'est imposé à mais bien
sûr je veux dire on a vous savez établir
un planning par rapport aux livraisons
de doses etc
et puis ce qu'on voit c'est que surtout
notre stratégie qui est basée sur
d'abord les plus âgés les plus fragiles
elle fonctionne regarder les courbes
épidémique sur les plus de 80 ans qui
ont été en priorité vacciner eh bien on
est sur une décroissance des
hospitalisations de la présence en
réanimation et c'est moins de kloster
dans les ehpad
donc tout ça justement produit des
effets et puis au fur et à mesure on
élargit les publics cibles c'est pour ça
qu'à un moment on évoquait la mi-avril
comme étant un peu un moment pivot où on
allait pouvoir et bien travaillé aussi
un certain nombre de réouverture
d'activités en tous les cas le présent
la publique police nous demander d'y
travailler donc moi la semaine prochaine
je réunirai d'ailleurs au cours de trois
réunions avec mon collègue alain griset
notamment isabelle borne les acteurs du
de l'hôtellerie de la restauration de
l'événementiel extra pour travailler à
ces conditions de repris ses modalités
de reprise
à quoi peuvent aussi se projeter à quoi
vous pensez justement pour pour imaginer
une réouverture progressive alors une
réouverture progressive ça peut se faire
déjà un identifiant
les lieux par catégorie il ya des lieux
dans lesquels on sait que la capacité de
diffusion du virus et est moindre tout
ce qui est naturellement plein air il y
en a pour lesquelles ça sera un peu plus
fort tout ce qui est intérieure donc il
faut aussi travailler au regard de deux
de cela et puis les professionnels sont
très engagées avec des protocoles
sanitaires très sérieux très rigoureux
il y avait aussi tout ce travail qui se
fait avec cédric au le scra natale
numérique pour enrichir tout senti
qu'ovide faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
traçabilité qui soit encore plus
améliorée notamment par exemple dans le
secteur de la restauration
vous savez vous souvenez lors des
premiers déconfinement les restaurateurs
tenait des cahiers dans lesquels les
gens à leurs salariés cedrico le
ministre du numérique parle d'un on
évoque le pass sanitaire avec un qr code
est ce que vous pouvez concrètement nous
expliquer comment ça pourrait
fonctionner si j'arrive ogm arrivent au
restaurant j'ai mon application
qu'est-ce que je fais là j'ai mon
application je flashe le qr code du
restaurateur donc on sait grâce à cela
quand je suis rentré quand je suis
sortie et si une personne un moment et
bien se déclare positive elle active
elle se met sur sur rouge prof et puis
les gens qui étaient au même endroit au
même moment se mouvoir recevoir une
alerte
ça permet derrière de mieux tracer
d'inciter les gens à les dépister parce
qu'ils étaient là au même endroit au
même moment
et puis ainsi de remonter les chaînes de
lutter contre contre le virus tout en
reprenant une vie plus normale parce que
c'est vrai je pense que ça pèse sur tout
le monde ça pèse sur le moral des
français
je dois dire d'ailleurs que si on
regarde les vacances de février
il ya eu globalement quand même un
certain nombre de départs et je crois
que c'est parce que les français avaient
besoin aussi de foxy général ça veut
dire que la cuillère panier sera
obligatoire pour aller au restaurant
quand les restaurants ouverts avec le qr
code sera obligatoire en terme
d'affichage et à ce moment-là ça permet
et on aura aux gens de le scanner et
pour ceux qui ne sont pas outillés de
matériel est bien là semblent être
entrés dans le restaurant si vous
refusez soit le qr code soit vous noté
dans le carnet à écouter tout ça on va
continuer à travailler et avec cédric
haut avec les professionnels mais il ya
un moment
la responsabilité c'est aussi de pas
être dans une démarche égoïste on est
chacun responsable de la santé des
autres on est dans ce moment où comment
dire
eh bien il faut être solidaire unie et
chacun détient une parcelle de la
capacité à reprendre puisque ce pas
sanitaire aussi il faudra pas rassuré
les gens parce que concrètement j'ai pas
peur j'ai pas envie que le restaurateur
connaissent si j'ai subi un test pcr si
j'ai enfin voilà aussi mais il ya comme
une protection des données que les siens
à portée mais vous savez d'ailleurs la
france depuis le début au niveau
européen parce que ce sont des débats
que nous avons aussi au niveau européen
la semaine dernière j'étais avec mes
collègues ministres du tourisme au
niveau européen la france est le pays
qui a justement toujours dit avec force
qu'ils avaient un certain nombre de
sujets éthiques et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous on se refuse à
parler de passeports vaccinale
c'est-à-dire de conditionner le le fait
d'accéder à certaines activités ou le
fait de voyager à l'étranger à
l'obligation vaccinale parce que on va
revenir sur ses pas excellent mais juste
sur le clair qu'au célèbre que pour les
restaurants vous y travaillez aussi pour
d'autres le touristique tpt les musées
et au monde et mécanique
roselyne bachelot il travaille aussi
dans le monde de la culture mais encore
une fois ce que je veux dire c'est que
on est dans ce processus
je parle d'un processus où on vient de
rentrer puisque chacun dans nos secteurs
on va réunir les publics avec lesquels
on travaille je dirais la semaine
prochaine donc
mais ça veut dire que la semaine
prochaine c'est pour travailler à des
réouvertures des lames et la vraie
je vais pas vous donner de deux bornes
exact puisque là aussi ça fait partie
des sujets qui vont être mis au débat à
la concertation comment les acteurs eux
voit-il les dates de reprise
il y aura sûrement différentes phases
souvenez vous on avait commencé parce
qu'ils étaient en plein air
il garde en est donc excusez moi
monsieur les moines mais j'imagine que
les professionnels ils vont vous
demander quand même plus ou moins une
date est ce que par exemple pour les
vacances de pâques
il est on se fixe cette date pour
essayer d'avoir un poids des protocoles
dans chaque secteur
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que justement
les professionnels et le premier
ministre réunit seul secteur hôtellerie
restauration j'étais à ses côtés
vendredi dernier nous a dit on en a
besoin d'un délai de prévenance de deux
à trois semaines donc c'est pour ça
qu'on fait ces travaux maintenant pour
pouvoir bien donner de la visibilité
vous le voyez d'ici la fin du mois de
mars en vue de se préparer à des actifs
mais les vacances de pâques elle
commence tout début avril donc ce qu'il
faut regarder
réserver vos vacances vous le regardez
au mois de février
les français ont pu partir en vacances
donc et donc a fortiori j'espère que la
situation à pâques sera encore meilleure
que celle que nous avons connue
vous savez même si un certain nombre de
lieux demeurent fermés et on fait tout
pour que ça soit le plus temporaire
possible les français ils ont besoin de
s'oxygéner ils ont besoin de prendre un
bol d'air et donc naturellement il ya
cette capacité à se déplacer il n'y a
pas de limitation est ce que vous
envisagez d'expérimenter d'ores et déjà
des réouvertures dans les départements
où le virus circule moins dans l'ouest
de la france est qu'au mois de mars vous
pourriez expérimenté dans certains
départements des réouvertures de jeu
alors la notion d'expérimentation elle
renvoie plutôt à autre chose
je pense que si on parle d'ouverture il
faut plutôt parler sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
en revanche les expérimentations elles
ont du sens sur des secteurs qui ont été
longtemps fermée pour lesquels il ya
besoin de mettre en place des protocoles
les acteurs y ont travaillé regardez
dans le monde de la culture des concerts
y en a pas eu depuis voilà très
longtemps dans le monde de
l'événementiel c'est pareil et j'ai eu
des propositions qui m'ont été faites
par les professionnels pour pouvoir
expérimentés tels kong par exemple un
congrès professionnel une fois et c'est
tout ça là ça mérite des
expérimentations infections pour avoir
mais ils comprennent des autorités
sanitaires qui eux peuvent vérifier quel
est l'impact de la tenue de l'événement
en thaïlande domaine du tourisme
justement au delà des congrès des choses
qui pourraient être expérimenté une part
très importante parce que le tourisme
d'affaires
c'est précisément ce qui manque à paris
et l'île de france depuis un an
c'est un moteur puissant et c'est ce qui
explique aussi que en matière de
tourisme
il ya des régions qui ont connu deux des
bons résultats lors de la saison d'été
derniers qui ont connu de bons résultats
et compris en février tout tout le
littoral atlantique a eu de très belles
réservation de biarritz à la bretagne
et puis après la normandie mais pour
autant il ya des territoires pour
lesquels c'était très dur et moi j'ai
vraiment eu une pensée pour les
hôteliers et les restaurateurs parisiens
parce que eux ont été privés d'une
clientèle internationale qui vient par
c'est par ces salons par ces congrès et
c'est pour ça que oui c'est une grosse
dit qu'il faut travailler un carnet
sanitaire et elle elle exclut pas la
question de la vaccination est ce que
vous travaillez avec elle sur ce sujet
comment faire revenir les touristes
étrangers comment faire revenir la
clientèle en matière de tourisme
on travaille main dans la main avec eux
les territoires avec les régions atout
france qui est le bras armé en matière
de promotion touristique de la france
nous travaillons aussi pour des
campagnes de promotion ensemble avec
avec les régions avec les territoires
j'étais moi-même la semaine dernière en
déplacement virtuel et l'asthme et
auprès des professionnels
du tourisme de la région centre val de
loire cette région avec tout tout tout
tout ce patrimoine fantastique ses
châteaux de la loire le zoo de beauval
et c est donc oui ce travail il se fait
avec les régions et sur la question du
vaccin pour le moment vous dit le
passeport vaccinale ce n'est pas
d'actualité parce qu'on peut pas se
faire vacciner mais est ce que disent
ils avaient mangé fait vacciner ses
excuses hier c'est que ça s'impose aussi
si les vacances d'été pour faire revenir
les touristes et les touristes étrangers
il faudra poser la question de ce
passeport vaccinale à ce qu'aulas tu
vous alors je peux vous dire les
réflexions qu'on a eues avec les
collègues baisse du tourisme dans
l'union européenne
c'est plutôt de se dire finalement
qu'est ce qui garantit qu'une personne
voyage dans de bonnes conditions
sanitaires et n'est pas en position de
de contaminés ou de transmettre le virus
ça peut être éventuellement le vaccin
jeudi éventuellement parce que les
études scientifiques sont en train
d'arriver sur quel est le lien entre la
vaccination et la non transmission du
virus
il ya une étude écossaise lac arrivé
quelques jours qui semblent aller dans
ce sens mais il ya besoin d'étayer une
vérité scientifique de ce point de vue
là mais ce qui reste l'élément le plus
sûr c'est la production d'un test pcr
négatif et c'est pourquoi il n'ya pas
besoin d'instaurer un passeport
vaccinale en fait il peut y avoir une
application
comment dire quelque chose qui a un
outil qui facilite les mobilités qui
permet de s'assurer que soit vous êtes
vacciné
soit vous avez votre test pcr négatif
éventuellement l'historique dtsp soeur
si ça voilà et est ainsi ça permet de
remettre de la fluidité dans les
déplacements
aussi je parle d'applications numériques
parce que pour l'instant on est les
tests pcr souvent sur du papier
il peut y avoir aussi de la fraude
documentaire il ya eu des motards et une
baisse de certaines filières et donc
c'est pourquoi c'est pour ça que ça met
de la sécurité sanitaire dans l'ensemble
de la chaîne en fait vous souhaitez à
aligner le passeport vaccinale avec le
pass sanitaire ce qui regroupe deux
réalités différentes
c'est différent on est bien d'accord
mais avec l'idée d'associer dans le
passeport ou vaccinale au même titre que
dans le passeport dans le pass sanitaire
que
vaccination ou tests pcr mais je le
terme de passeports vaccinale moi je
n'aime pas je le dis parce que la notion
de passeport ça laisse entendre que vous
pouvez vous ne pouvez pas voyager donc
se fera que c'est le jeu il faut des
consensus évoqué effectivement
l'application une application numérique
hectares à l'échelle de l'union
européenne à bas toutes façons beaucoup
sont en train d'y réfléchir pas que dans
l'union européenne partout dans le monde
donc un moment d'ailleurs il faudra
travailler à une interopérabilité
je précise d'ailleurs que certaines
compagnies aériennes ont d'ores et déjà
mis en place des pilotes par exemple air
france expérimente sur les antilles un
dispositif travailler avec international
sos afin de justement
dématérialiser la production de ce test
pcr donc ça montre que je crois que les
techniciens sont à sont au travail et un
moment il faudra arriver à rendre tout
ça intéropérables un navire allemand
qu'ils aient pas trente six mille on va
parler de la montagne avant de laisser
la parole à julien sur ce sujet vous
nous avez dit les vacances de février ça
a bien marché du côté de la côte
atlantique du côté de la normandie en
alors aux montagnes oui bien sûr la
situation est différenciée selon les
massifs selon les selon qu'on est en
basse moyenne ou haute altitude
globalement ça pas mal fonctionné dans
des massifs comme le jura les vosges
les pyrénées mais en revanche dans les
alpes c'est vrai qu'une destination
comme savoie mont blanc par exemple a
été particulièrement touchée impacté les
stations de haute altitude on voit ce
différentiel les pyrénées par exemple
ont perdu 33 1 40% à peu près de l'heure
de la fréquentation dans les alpes c'est
monté plus tôt à 50 55 % donc on voit
bien que
voilà l'impact différencié maintenant il
ya aussi beaucoup de français qui sont
partis à la montagne et qui d'ailleurs
ont pratiqué des activités qu'ils ne
pratiquaient peut-être pas d'ordinaire
les activités nordiques qui ont connu un
essor phénoménal qui ont re découvert la
montagne différemment j'espère que ça
restera au sens où et bien il ya une
diversification des activités
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que on voit
aussi que la montagne sans la remontée
mécanique il sent le ski alpin et bien
ce n'est pas non plus tout à fait la
montagne vous les mettez vous le pont
était justement monsieur liste parce que
les stations de haute montagne sont
clairement calibré pour le pour le ski
alpin qui sert de locomotive à
l'économie sens là sont ils sont perdus
ils sont des faits c'est un article du
monde là qu'il qu'il notait encore ce
matin est ce que
dans le plan d'investissement que vous
comptez à monter pour le secteur de la
de la montagne il n'y a pas cette
obligation de revoir la stratégie
globale de ces de ses stations et de
leur dire finalement profitons de cette
de cette crise pour ce nous transformer
alors tout à fait c'est toutes les
bonnes questions qu'on va se poser
d'ailleurs je suis demain à chamonix
avec joël giraud le sucre est à la
ruralité pour lancer les travaux de
concertation et cédric au je crois et
c'est alors cedrico effectivement nous
rejoindra puisqu'il ya une dimension on
va inaugurer un pylône aussi vous savez
qu'on fait beaucoup pour que justement
la 4g arrive partout sur le territoire
et donc je reviens au plan
d'investissement montagne on lance les
travaux demain pendant quatre à six
semaines
le premier ministre justement d'ici la
fin avril début mai pour a présenté
après les fruits de cette concertation
et l'idée vous avez raison en fait notre
politique elle est sûre de pied pied
numéro un réparez réparer parce que le
fait que lier pas de clientèle
internationale que les remontées
mécaniques a été fermé ça veut dire
qu'il ya besoin de soutien immédiat en
trésorerie en aide et ça c'est le fonds
de solidarité qu'on a adapté on a fait
en sorte par exemple que les commerces y
compris non seulement dans les stations
mais dans les vallées puisse être
éligible à ces dispositifs
on est en discussion avec bruxelles
j'espère parce que les régies de
remonter le nir le feu vert définitif
sur notre aide qui vise à compenser à
70% leurs coûts fixes
donc vous avez vu que ça c'est le volet
réparer et puis un deuxième pilier
deuxième pièce est préparé si on veut
rester de façon générale le numéro un en
termes d'attractivité internationale de
tourisme
et puis hélas on avait on était un peu
descendu dans le podium en matière de de
tourisme de neige puisque on s'est fait
coiffer sur le poteau par les
autrichiens il ya déjà quelques années
on a besoin de repartir à l'offensive
effectivement deux
de penser à l'évolution du secteur et je
le sais j'étais au congrès de domaines
skiables de france en octobre dernier
eux mêmes sont très engagés
réfléchissent à l'avenir le président
alex mollahs jouant très dynamique avec
avec ses troupes pour anticiper c'est
quoi le le tourisme de demain à la
montagne et donc ça va être l'objet de
ces quatre à six semaines de travail
on va aller dans chacun des massifs pour
y travailler que les acteurs un petit
mot sur les sur les aide parce que les
plus touchés et les moins aidés sont
laissons les saisonniers seuls trente
mille d'entre 1 soit environ un quart
des saisonniers de montagne ont pu être
embauchés et avoir accès donc au chômage
partiel
et qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
eux très concrètement alors les
saisonniers on a dit dès le début au
mois de décembre isabelle borne avait
dit ceux qui seront embauchés justement
pour en bénéficier les fils d'or
s'échangeait parti voilà et c'est
pourquoi tout ça fait de sécurité
important ça promet la question s'était
déjà posée pour les saisonniers de l'été
notamment géante est la situation de
lourdes et donc nous avions mis en nous
avons mis en place une sorte de filet de
sécurité
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas byzance
mais ce filet de sécurité de 900 euros
pour tenir parce que certains sinon on
se retrouvait avec le quasiment rien et
donc que ce dispositif
il est là pour répondre à ces situations
ok à combien estimez vous en faites
aujourd'hui les aides qui ont déjà été
apportées à la au secteur de la montagne
on a parlé du chiffre de 4000 heures
c'était début février on a aujourd'hui
presque à la mi mars donc le compteur il
a continué à tourner jean-luc boeck le
président de l'anem sm évoqué un manque
à gagner de 5 milliards je pense que ce
manque à gagner il va être couvert en
réalité parce que depuis et bien les les
fonds vont continuer à être décaissés
bien sûr les conflits nationaux
oui il ya beaucoup d'histoires d'amour
qui sont perturbés et bousculé par la
crise sanitaire et notamment celle des
couples binationaux qui sont privés de
ceux de se voir depuis depuis un an
qu'est ce que vous allez concrètement
faire pour alors ce qu'on a mis en place
c'était au mois d'août dernier c'était à
une dérogation pour permettre de se
retrouver lorsqu'on était ni mariée ni
pacsé et dès lors qu'on pouvait
montrer qu'ils cette relation existe et
qu'on avait ce partenaire de coeur dont
on était séparés et bien nos consulats
ont délivré 2500 laissez-passer
dérogatoire permettant à autant de
coupes de se retrouver ses 80 % des
dossiers qui ont été acceptées
maintenant vous depuis le 29 janvier
nous vivons tous sous le régime des
motifs impérieux qui limite la mobilité
internationale et c'est pas un motif
impérieux et donc le dispositif a été
suspendu voilà donc s'agissant par
exemple des français établis hors de
france
je travaille à l'assouplissement de ses
motifs impérieux pour des ddt raisons
familiales et naturellement j'ai
toujours en tête la situation de ces
couples pour lesquelles je sais c'est
pas facile et c'est pourquoi j'ai
demandé à nos consulats de continuer à
instruire des dossiers qu'il recevait
pour que dès qu'on pourra lever un
certain nombre de contraintes à la
mobilité il n'est pas attendre six
semaines avant de pouvoir retrouver
leurs compagnons leurs amis
mais quel horizon vous leur donnez
faisais moi parce que là on fait
aujourd'hui quand caen mais ça peut être
quoique non quatre à six semaines c'est
plusieurs mois c'est quoi écoutez je ne
veux pas créer de faux espoirs faire de
fausses promesses donc je ne peux pas
donner de date
aujourd'hui ce qui est sûr c'est que on
ne les oublie pas on fait ce travail
aussi concernant les français établis
hors de france et j'espère qu'on pourra
les inscrire aussi dans cette dynamique
où progressivement desserrent l'étau et
on permet la reprise des mobilités
international sera rapidement voilà
exactement
merci beaucoup merci jean baptiste
lemoyne nous est venue nous voir ce
matin merci julien lécuyer on regarde la
une de la voix du nord c'est la
cohabitation entre seniors est une autre
moyen aussi de gérer l'isolément en ces
temps
de crise sanitaire à 2 pour se sentir
moins seuls ces votes au titre merci je
veux dire merci a bientot et ont fait
suite au clash des titans la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente
[Musique]